follow me
enter the multiverse of infinite
possibilities
[Music]
[Music]
citizens repair yourselves
what if
thor
was an only child
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and it
looks like this week on marvel's what if
we are finally getting party thor party
thor had been teased for a very long
time since before we even got the first
episode and i know a lot of us have been
waiting for him for a while but now
marvel has actually released an official
clip for the party thor episode and we
now know what the episode is truly about
and that comes with the official title
for this episode what if thor was an
only child so essentially what if thor
did not have loki as a brother and they
do give us a little bit of context here
within this clip but if you're new and
you want to stay up to date on marvel be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so in the
start of this clip we of course hear the
watcher and he says follow me enter the
multiverse of infinite possibilities and
we find out what exactly is different in
the universe that we are going into and
as we see on the tva screen the normal
universe went like this while traveling
jodenhein odin found an abandoned baby
frost giant which he brought back to
asgard he named the child loki and
raised him as a brother to thor that is
what we saw that led to basically all of
the events of the mcu maybe minus a few
but most of the stuff that happened was
either a direct cause of loki his
influence or the repercussions of what
he did in some way shape or form so this
universe is going to be way way
different because as we can see them
type on the tva screen odin went down a
different path therefore leading the
universe to be completely different than
the normal sacred timeline they now
changed it to while traversing yodenhein
odin found an abandoned baby frost giant
which he returned to his family thor was
raised as an only child and they keep
saying only child but here they say he
was raised as an only child i wonder if
he truly is an only child in this
episode because odin still had hella
even though he locked her up he still
had her so i'm wondering if she'll make
a debut in this episode somehow but as
we can see loki not being there actually
really affected thor and now we have
party thor so it kind of seems like loki
was the one kind of holding thor back
from being this big partier loki was
kind of a voice of reason in a lot of
situations for thor and since he wasn't
there thor kind of went off and did
whatever he wanted to we hear him say
that it's time to party on asgard and we
also see him dancing in what seems to be
some sort of a club probably on asgard
although it does look like we see the
bifrost send thor to earth or at least
somebody to earth and we do see jane
foster and what appears to be darcy
lewis and the truck as the bifrost comes
it also does look like we have a repeat
of the avengers scene where loki comes
to earth and then goes to germany to get
an eyeball he then goes outside and
fights captain america looks like this
is a very similar scene here as the
building looks to be the same now it
doesn't seem like loki is going to be
the one showing up there telling
everybody to kneel so why this scene
could they be showing us something that
originally happened like they've done
before and what if they could simply be
showing what happens in the normal
universe during the normal sacred
timeline and then we get into the what
if part or perhaps party thor at one
point in time wants to actually rule the
world we'll have to wait and see but
luckily we do not have much longer to
wait as marvel's what if thor was an
only child comes out tonight slash
tomorrow but i will be doing my live
watch party at 11 30 p.m pacific time so
if you'd like to join that's when we
will be live in the meantime let me know
what you think about this clip of party
thor don't forget to subscribe and like
this video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof